[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصفه الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا مع هذه اللقطات من
نيويورك وجلسه في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده تناقش الوضع الانساني في سوريا
وملف المفقودين فيها
وهذه الصور تريدون مباشره من الحرم المكي
وتعكس الاجواء في شهر رمضان بعيدا انتهاء
صلاه التراويح اليوم
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
قانون رفع سن التقاعد بوابه صدام بين
ماكرون والنقابات في فرنسا مع استمرار
تظاهر مئات الالاف في باريس ومدن اخرى
صدامات واعتقالات والسلطات تطالب الاحزاب
بموقف واضح لادانه العنف
النقابات تؤكد تلقيها دعوه للقاء رئيسه
الحكومه ومنظمون الاحتجاجات يعلنون تنظيم
موجه جديده الاسبوع المقبل
روسي على خط التصعيد في شرق اسيا بعد
اختبار موسكو صاروخا فرد صوتي في بحر
اليابان واشنطن تقول ان لديها ما يكفي من
القدره لحمايه مصالحها ومصالح حلفائها في
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وتدفع بحامله
طائرات للمشاركه في مناورات مع الشغل
وبيونجيان تختبر قدراتها على شم هجوم
نوويه مضاد
مع استمرار الحديث الاوكراني عن الهجوم
المضاد في الربيع امدادات غربيه مستمره
مدرعات ودبابات امريكيه وبريطانيه
والمانيه تصلك يقول ان القوات الروسيه
استنفذت مخزوناتها من المدرعات بشكل لم
تكن تتخيله موسكو تتهم الغرب بتصعيد
انخراط في الحرب
على وقع تشكيك بنيه نتنياهو الرئاسه
الاسرائيليه تعلن بدء جولات تفاوض بين
الائتلاف الحكومي والمعارضه بشان قانون
التعديلات القضائيه وبعيد اعلان اتفاق
نتانياهو على مشروع الحرس الوطني
يصفه بالخطوه الجنونيه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اتساع دائره الغضب في
انحاء فرنسا مع استمرار الاحتجاجات
الرافضه لرفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى
64 هذه الاحتجاجات يقابلها اصرار من
الرئيس ايميويل ماكرون والحكومه على المضي
قدما في تنفيذ التعديلات لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما المالات المحتمله
للاحتجاجات في فرنسا وقد جاءت النتيجه كما
يلي نحو 35% قالوا ان الحكومه
ستتراجع عن تعديل قانون التقاعد بينما صوت
نحو 20% لتنفيذ التعديلات وانتهاء
الاحتجاجات في حين راى 45% ان الاحتجاجات
ستؤدي الى التصاعدها واستقاله الحكومه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا على وقع ازمه
فرضتها السجلات والسياسه بعيدا يقول ان
الولايات المتحده ستستعيد الصداره في
صناعه اشباه الموصلات
رفض مستمر لقانون رفع سن التقاعد في فرنسا
خلال هذا اليوم اتسعت رقعه الاحتجاجات
لتعم العديد من المدن الفرنسيه وعلى راسها
العاصمه باريس وقد قدرت النقابات عدد
المتظاهرين في عموم فرنسا بنحو مليون
بينما قدرتهم الداخليه ب 750 الفا كما
تواصلت الاضرابات لتشمل قطاع السياحه اذ
اغلقت رموز باريس السياحيه مثل قصر فيرساي
وبرج ايفال امام السياح ونظمت النقابات
اضرابات تشمل القطاعات العماليه
والتعليميه كافه بينما شددت السلطات
الاجراءات الامنيه التي وصفت بغير
المسبوقه فقد قال وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
انه نشر ثلاثه عشر الف شرطي وتعهد بتفكيك
المجموعات المتطرفه حسب تعبيره وبعدم
السماح بالعنف
وتحولت الاحتجاجات في عده مناطق في فرنسا
الى اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين وقوات الامن
التي اطلقت القنابل المسيله للدموع على
المحتاجين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واندلعت مواجهات بين قوات الامن الفرنسيه
ومتظاهرين في مدينه ليون الجنوبيه البلاد
وقد اقدم متظاهرون على تحطيم ابواب مؤسسات
ماليه ومحال تجاريه في المدينه
وكان مراسل الجزيره قد افاد ان متظاهرين
فرنسيين احتلوا محطه
للقطارات في مرسيليا الجنوب البلاد هذا
ودهم محتاجون مطار بياريتس جنوب غربي
فرنسا في اطار الاحتجاجات المستمره رفضا
لقانون التقاعد واطلق المتظاهرون قنابل
دوخانيه باتجاه مدخل المطار مما تسبب في
تفعيل صفارات الانذار
في هذه الاثناء حذر زعيم حزبي فرنسا
الابيه اليسري جونيك الرئيس ماكرون من ان
الغضبه يتصاعد وقال ان عليه ان يستمع
للجماهير
انها معركه الحريه وهي معركه لا تناقش
وانما تمارس وممارساتنا لها تفيد باننا لا
نرغب في تقاعد بعمر 64 عاما لا شرعيه لذلك
نحن ننتقل نحو نمط استبداادي وعنيف
والجميع يلاحظون ذلك ماذا يجب ان نفعل
علينا ان نواصل انه الامر الوحيد الذي في
متناول ايدينا ماذا يمكننا فعله غير ذلك
انها اراده الشعب الفرنسي في مواجهه اراده
الحكومه التي اتخذت قرارها اكرر يجب ان
نواصل حتى التراجع عن ذلك
في المقابل دعت الحكومه الفرنسيه الاحزاب
والقوى السياسيه الى ادانه العنف واكد
بيان للحكومه ان فرنسا ستبقى حصنا ضد ما
وصفه بالعنف والمجموعات المتطرفه العنيفه
واشار البيان الى ان المظاهرات لا ينبغي
ان تتحول الى العنف وان الخطاب السياسي
يجب ان يبقى منضبطا اضاف بيان الحكومه
الفرنسيه انه لا توجد وساطه مع اي طرف في
وقت يمكن فيه الحديث بشكل مباشر مع جميع
الفرنسيين
هذا وقالت الاطراف المنظمه للاحتجاجات
انها ستعمل على تنظيم موجه جديده من
الاحتجاجات في السادس من الشهر المقبل
وكانت صحيفه ليبراسيون الفرنسيه نقلت عن
لرامي رئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي الديمقراطي
للعمل وهو اكبر نقابه عماليه في فرنسا ان
رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه اليزابيث بورن
ستدعو النقابات للاجتماع يوم الاثنين او
الثلاثاء المقبلين في مقر الحكومه ياتي
هذا اللقاء المرتقب منذ بعد نحو شهرين من
بدايه التحركات الاحتجاجيه رفضا لما
تضمنته تعديلات قانون التقاعد التي رفعت
سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64
يتمسك هؤلاء بموقفهم يرفضون رفع سن
التقاعدي في فرنسا
ولهذا باتت الشوارع والمرافق الاقتصاديه
هدفا لتحركاتهم
الحكومه تصر انها لن تحيد عن تطبيق ما
تسميه اصلاح نظام التقاعد فما هي اسباب
الشقاق بين الفرنسيين وحكومتهم
ينص التعديل القانون على رفع سن التقاعد
من 62 الى 64 عاما تدريجيا وصولا لعام
2030 وزياده مده الاشتراكات المطلوبه في
الضمان الاجتماعي من 42 الى ثلاثه واربعين
عاما لكي يحصل المتقاعد على معاشه كاملا
اتفقت النقابات على رفض التعديل لكن المهن
الاكثر تضررا هي تلك التي يستفيد العاملون
فيها من التقاعد المبكر مثل عمال السكك
الحديديه وسائقي القطارات حيث سيتم توحيد
التقاعد في نظام واحد قائم على النقاط
ويخشى العمال انه بموجب نظام التقاعد
الجديد سيتعين عليهم العمل لفتره اطول
وزياده الاقتطاعات من رواتبهم اما الحكومه
فترى في النظام الجديد محاوله لجعل نظام
المعاش التقاعدي قابلا للاستمرار
وتوفير قرابه في 19 مليار دولار من
ميزانيه الدوله سنويا
وتنفق فرنسا بحسب ارقام رسميه قرابه 14%
من الناتج المحلي على برنامج التقاعد
مقابل 57
في الولايات المتحده وعشره واربعه اعشار
في المئه في المانيا لكن معدلات الضرائب
في فرنسا تعتبر من الاعلى اوروبيا ولهذا
اقترحت النقابات بدائل على الحكومه تتركز
حول فرض ضرائب عادله على الاثرياء ورفع
مساهمه ارباب العمل في صناديق التقاعد وهو
ما ترفضه الحكومه فالغضب الشعبي الذي
تشهده المدن الفرنسيه ينبع من خشيه حقيقيه
لدى الفرنسيين ان يكون تعديل قانون
التقاعد خطوه اولى ستقربهم اكثر مما
يسميها ايمانويل ماكرون اصلاحات اقتصاديه
تخشى النقابات ان يدفع ثمنها اصحاب الدخل
المحدود
من باريس ينضم الينا الباحث السياسي صلاح
القادر مرحبا بك سيد صلاح اي منحه ستتخذه
هذه الازمه بعد المظاهرات التي شهدتها مدن
فرنسا اليوم
مساء الخير سيدتي الكريمه الذي يحصل الان
هو بدايته كانت حينما ارادت الحكومه
الفرنسيه وحكومه ايمانيول ماكرون الذهاب
مباشره الى استعمال الفصل 49 ثلاثه والذي
كان فصلا يعني يعتبر غير ديمقراطي لان
الاراده الشعبيه المتمثله في المؤسسات
المنتخبه على راسها البرلمان رفضت هذا
التعديل الاصلاء او تعديل نظام التقاعد
الحكومه اصلاح وكذلك استطلاعات الشعب كانت
تقول بانها لا تريد هذا النظام الان
ايمانويل ماكرون استعمل هذا الفصل الذي
يمنح له الحق في في سن هذا القانون حتى
وان كان البرلمان رافضا هو قد نقل المعركه
من التدافع السياسي المتمثل في المساحه
البرلمانيه والمظاهرات السلميه الى سياسه
فرد الامر الواقع فحينما اراد حكومته فرض
الامر الواقعي على الفرنسيين خرج
الفرنسيون ونقلوا حاولوا ان يربحوا هذه
التي تحولت الى معركه كسر عظمنا الان بين
النقابات والقطاعات الشعبيه من جهه
والاحزاب المعارضه وبين الاحزاب التي هي
مواليه للسلطه وعلى راسها حزب ايمانيويل
ماكرون الان انتقلنا من ساحه التدافع
السياسي الى ساحه معركه فرض الامر الواقع
وكسر العظم وهذا ما يمكن الان بتصعيد
وخصوصا ونحن نرى الى ممارسات او او مظاهر
لم نكن نراها في فرنسا منذ منذ تقريبا منذ
سنه 1968 والمظاهرات الشهيره في باريس
التي اسقطت الحكومه انذاك
المشاهد الى اليوم بعدما جرى اليوم هناك
دعوه يفترض ان توجهها رئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيث بورن للنقابات للحوار يومي
الاثنين والثلاثاء هل يمكن ان يشكل هذا
الامر اختراقا
للاسف لا ارى انه يمثل اختراقا لان هناك
رئيس الكونفدراليه الفرنسيه للعمال
الفرنسيين الذين الذي قال اليوم بانه يطلب
وساطه بين الحكومه الفرنسيه والنقابات لكن
رد الحكومه كان واضحا بانه لا يمكن ان
يقبلوا ببساطه وانهم مستعدون ان يتكلموا
مع الجميع رفض الوساطه ان نتكلم مع الجميع
معناه باننا سنستمر في سن هذا القانون وان
نفرضه كامر واقع عن الفرنسيين جميعهم ولكن
الذي يريد ان يتفاوض نحن تعالوا لنتكلم
هذه هي الاشكاليه الان النقبات تريد
والقطاعات الشعبيه تريد ان نبدا المفاوضات
من الصفر القانون الحكومه تريد ان تقول
صلاح لماذا يريدون وساطه
ولا يريدون الحديث مباشره مع الحكومه يعني
ما الفارق هنا
الفرق بين الوساطه
والوساطه الوساطه هي بين طرفين
لديهما نفس الوزن ولديهما نفس الموقع في
التفاوض اما حينما نتكلم عن حديث بما ان
انا الذي افرض مفردات الخطاب وكذلك
القضايا التي سنتفاوض عليها وسقف التفاوض
اما في الوساطه لا يوجد سقف للتفاوض هذه
الاشكاليه ان الحكومه لا تريد وساطه لان
الوساطه لان لا يوجد سقف للتفاوض
سقف التفاوض لديها هو بعض التعديلات
الممكنه وقد تكون تعديلات شكليه فقط على
القانون الجديد للتقاعد ولكنه ليست اعاده
النظر في القانون في حد ذاته او سحبه من
جديد طيب الانظار كلها متوجهه ايضا الى
المجلس الدستوري الذي يفترض ان يكون ان
تكون كلمته هي الحاسمه في كل ما يحصل
باعتقادك ما هو توجه هذا المجلس
للاسف المجلس حتى وان كان سمي دستوريه لان
التحرك التي قامت به الحكومه الفرنسيه كان
تحركا يعني قانونيا لان وجود الفصل 49
ثلاثه الذي يمنح الحق للسلطه التنفيذيه
وعلى راسها الرئيس الى فرض اي قانون في
حال ما راى انه هناك تعارض كبير او تصادم
كبير بين الاراده السلطه التشريعيه
والسلطه التنفيذيه وفي حال رفض هذه عرفت
هذا التمرير القانون به استعمال هذا الفصل
يحق
هناك حل للبرلمان من جديد وبعد هذا الحل
نتوجه تتوجه
البرلمان الى انتخابات جديده وبالتالي
برلمان جديد لكن للاسف ان البرلمان لم
يقبل بحل هذا هذا هذا
الحل حل حل لنفسه والدعوه الى انتخابات
جديده وبالتالي اظن ان المس الدستوري اذا
حكم على على الامر من ناحيه شكل القانون
البحث فانه سيقول بان تحرك الحكومه هو
تحرك قانوني لكن المجلس الدستوري لا يمكن
ان يرى فقط بعين القانونيه البحته لمثل
هذه المواضيع لان الوضع الوضع خطير جدا
جدا جدا وبالتالي هو يريد ان يرى ان اذا
قام بتاييد الحكومه في تصرفها وتحركها هو
سيدفع وسيؤجل الانتخابات الاحتجاجات التي
وصلت الى درجه خطيره جدا استعمال
التعدي على المقرات الحزبيه على المؤسسات
العموميه الاستيلاء على المقرات وعلى
محطات القطار والمطارات هذه لم تشهدها
فرنسا منذ 55 سنه نحن نشهد تصعيد جديد
وكبير جدا لذلك لن يكتفي بشكل قانون بل
يذهب الى روح القانون وحمايه فرنسا من
حاله كارثيه قد تسببها تصاعد الاحتجاجات
شكرا لك من باريس الباحث السياسي صلاح
القادري
[موسيقى]
حاله توتر ورسائل مختلفه مسرحها المحيط
الهادئ وبحر اليابان الحقا بحاله التوتر
القائمه اصلا في بحر جنوب الصين فروسيا
اعلنت اطلاقا صاروخ فرض صوتي مضاد للسفن
في بحر اليابان وتسارعت المناورات الجويه
والبحريه والتجارب الصاروخيه بين الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه بالمقابل سرعت
كوريا الشماليه تجاربها النوويه وكشفت
لاول مره عن راس حربي نووي تكتيكي
بحر اليابان مسرح توتر جديد بين موسكو
وطوكيو باعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اختبار اسطولها البحري في المحيط الهادئ
لصاروخ كروز فرد صوتي مضاد للسفن من طرز
موسكيت يمكن ان يشكل تهديدا للقطع البحريه
الكبيره
اوضحت الوزاره ان صاروخ موسكت متوسط المدى
تمكن من ضرب هدف وهمي من مسافه تقدر بنحو
100 كم ويمكنه تدمير سفينه على بعد 120
كيلومترا وجاءت التجربه بعد اسبوع من
تحليق قاذفتين استراتيجيتين روسيتين
قادرتين على حمل رؤوس نوويه فوق بحر
اليابان وذلك لاكثر من سبع ساعات رافقتها
مقاتله حربيه خطوه اذنتها اليابان وقالت
انها ستظل يقظه حيله تحركات موسكو وكانت
تعهدت لكييف بالدعم خلال زياره رئيس
الوزراءها بعد ان رفعت ميزانيه دفاعها
وغيرت من عقيدتها الدفاعيه في البحر ذاته
تستعرض كوريا الشماليه عضلاتها زعيمها كيم
جونغ اون سرع من وتيره استعدادات بلاده في
مجال استخدام اسلحه نوويه كقوه ردع في وجه
ما سماها القوه النوويه المتفوقه التي
تتجاوز الخيال
كشفت لاول مره عن راس حربي نووي تكتيكي في
استعراض واضح على انه يمكنها وضع مثل هذه
الرؤوس الحربيه على قاذفات الصواريخ
متعدده كبيره الحجم او صواريخ كروز تجربه
تاتي مع تسارع المناورات الجويه والبحريه
والتجارب الصاروخيه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه من جهه وكوريا الشماليه
من جهه اخرى
فحامله الطائره الامريكيه يو اس اس التي
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه وصلت الى قاعده
بوسان البحريه بكوريا الجنوبيه وعلى متنها
اكثر من 80 مقاتله حربيه لتنفيذ مناورات
مع السفن حربيه كوريه جنوبيه
اتساع دائره استعراض القدرات جعلت رئيس
الوزراء الياباني يحذر من ان شرق اسيا قد
يكون اوكرانيا التاليه فاموسكو نشرت
صواريخ دفاعيه ساحليه من طراز باستيون في
جزر الكوريل المتنازع عليها مع اليابان
وقد تضاعف نشر محطات رادار لانظمه الانذار
بالهجوم الصاروخي قرب الجزر لتغطيه جميع
مناطق بحر اليابان وتوفير حمايه للاسطول
الروسي في المحيط الهادئ التحركات
الامريكيه تاتي ايضا بينما تحول بحر جنوب
الصين الى ساحه مواجهه حيث تتبادل واشنطن
وبيجين الاتهامات وتتنازع الصين مع
الفلبين وماليزيا وفيتنام وتايوان السياده
في هذه المنطقه وبينما اجرت روسيا والصين
مناورات مشتركه نهايه العام الماضي في بحر
جنوب الصين اعلنت بيجين ابعاد المدمره
الامريكيه يو اس اس ميليوس بعد ان دخلت
البحر مما يعكس حاله التوتر في هذه
المنطقه
ينضم الينا من موسكو استروكان الباحث في
المجلس الروسي للشؤون الدوليه ومعنى من
واشنطن
المستشار السابق للرئيس الامريكي لشؤون
الامن القومي ومسؤول شؤون اليابان في معهد
ترومان للامن القومي سابقا مرحبا بكما سيد
تروكان اذا صاروخ موسكت على هدف وهمي في
بحر اليابان ما الرساله الروسيه من وراء
اطلاق هذا الصاروخ ولمن هي موجهه
[موسيقى]
اليوم كل الانظار كانت موجهه نحو اوكرانيا
والمواجهه العسكريه في اوكرانيا لكن من
خلال هذه المناورات البحريه الاف الاميال
بعيده عن اوكرانيا ارادت موسكو ارسال
رساله واضحه بانها هي ايضا قوه في المحيط
الهادئ لا يستهان بها
طبعا ربما كان ينبغي ان نبعث بهذه الرساله
منذ فتره طويله لا يوجد شيء استثنائي من
حيث هذا
الاطلاق للصواريخ موسكيتو هو صاروخ مضاد
للسفن واذا ما القينا نظره على الموقع فهو
خليط
بطرس الاعظم والاكبر اذا هي ارض او مياه
اقليميه روسيه
والتدريب هذا تدريب
وجزء من تهيئه المعدات الروسيه ومن ورائه
رساله سياسيه فيه الكثير من المضامين طبعا
معروف ان الامريكيون يترون تدريباتهم مع
كوريا الجنوبيه
وراينا قبل ايام فقط هم انهو تلك
التدريبات لكن عدا عن ذلك
فان هذه التمرينات اتت بعد ايام فقط من
زياره
التاريخيه الى روسيا فاذا بامكاننا ان
نتوقع
تعزيزا
للقدرات
للقدرات الصينيه والروسيه في هذا الجزء من
العالم اذا هناك رساله اريد ان اتوقف معك
سيد سروكان لاذهب الى جوش ووكر اذا من
وراء هذه الخطوه سيده جوشوا هناك رساله
روسيه تريد القول بان روسيا هي قوه لا
يستهان بها في المحيط الهادئ وايضا ان
هناك تقاربا روسيا صينيا سينعكس كذلك في
المنطقه كيف تراقب الولايات المتحده كل
ذلك
تنظر الى هذه العمليه كعمليه روتينيه كما
قال الضيف الروسي لكن اذا ما اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار الزياره التاريخيه بين
هذا يعطي اهميه لليابان اليابان الرساله
الموجهه اليها والتي لا خطا فيها بان
روسيا تريد ان ينظر اليها كقوه عالميه لكن
للاسف هذه ستدفع كثيرا من الحلفاء
الامريكيين للاقتراب اكثر من الجانب
الامريكي فكلما استمر العدوان الروسي في
اوكرانيا فسيكون هناك المزيد من التوجه
هنا امريكا وكلما توجهت الجهود الروسيه
نحو اليابان نحن ندرك انها عمليه روتينيه
لكن الرساله هي ماذا يمكن ان نفعل لكي
يفهم كل حلفائنا في المنطقه التزامنا بهم
اليابانيون
واضح هم لا يريدون ان تمر هذه الرسائل
مرور الكرام واضافه الى حلفائنا الاخرين
في المنطقه مع استمرار روسيا في عدوان في
اوكرانيا واستعراض قوتها في المحيط الهادئ
ايضا كيف تقرا روسيا هكذا امكانيات سيد
ستروكان ان تؤدي مثل هذه التصرفات الروسيه
في المنطقه الى نتائج عكسيه الى التقويه
التحالف مع الولايات المتحده الى تعزيز
تواجد الناتو في تلك المنطقه
النقطه الاولى المهمه هنا ان علينا ان
نميز بين النزاع في اوكرانيا وما يحدث في
الشرق الاقصى نحن لن نقوم باي شكل من
الاشكال بابتزازي اليابان او غيرها من
خلال
مزاعم حول اراضي مختلف عليها بالتاكيد هذه
ليست القضيه لكننا في ذات الوقت ندرك
ادراكا كاملا كاملا ان الاداره الحاليه في
طوكيو قد فعلت المزيد من تعزيز القدرات
العسكريه اليابان اكثر من اي حكومه اخرى
في سنوات او ربما في عقود لهذا السبب
اليابان وهذا معروف
تعزز من قواتها العسكريه ونحن علينا ان
نرد على هذه الحاله ايضا هناك نقطه اخرى
مهمه هي ان الولايات المتحده كوريا
الجنوبيه تحاولان بناء مثلث اضلاعه
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان وايضا اذا ما اخذنا بعنا اعتبار
انهم يحاولون
الرزعه الصين كقوه من خلال هذا المثلث اذا
نحن لا يمكننا ان نجلس مكتوب فيها الايدي
ونراقب المشهد من بعض لهذا السبب من خلال
هذه التمرينات نحن نبين على اهبه
الاستعداد لا نحاول استفزاز الاخرين لكن
نطقي على قواتنا على اهبه الاستعداد كما
يقال وان نكون مستعدين للتصدي لاي عدوان
اذا ما وقع
ايضا هناك وجهه نظر لدى روسيا وحلفائها
تقول بان اصلا المسؤول عن اثاره كل
التوترات في المنطقه هي الولايات المتحده
عبر دخولها على خط التوتر وعلى خط
استثاره النزاعات ربما بين هذه الدول
المتجاوره وما النتيجه النتيجه الان زياده
التوتر امكانات حدوث صدام الان ايضا لدينا
التهديد من كوريا الشماليه بوجود رؤوس
حربيه تكتيكيه كيف يمكن ان تتعامل مع
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في حال خروج
الامور عن السيطره في تلك المنطقه
المتحده هي المسؤوله عن ما يدور حاليا في
العالم عندما ننظر الى ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا عندما ننظر الى النقل صواريخ
تكتيكيه نوويه الى بيلاروسيا وعندما نرى
كل هذه المناورات امريكا بالطبع تريد من
حلفائها ان يكونون مستعدين ولكن هون الذين
يلقون باللائمه على الوقت المتحده هم
الذين لا يريدون النظام الدولي الراهن ان
يستمر امريكا لم تخترق هذا النظام روسيا
التي فعلت ذلك لكن ما هو موقف الصين ما هي
خطط الصين المستقبل تحدثتم عن كوريا
الجنوبيه ولم نستطع نحن ان نفصل في هذه
القضيه لعدم وجود اتفاق بين روسيا والصين
وكوريا الشماليه اذا كلنا لدينا الحوافز
للتخفيف من الحده حده الموقف والم على
الوضع الراهن لكنني ارى بان اليابان تلعب
دورا اكبر نعم هذا لانها ترى عدوانيه
جيراننا وخاصه الروس على المدى البعيد
سيكون لهذا كله اثار اكبر
ايضا يفعلوا اشياء في الشرق الاوسط بين
السعوديه وايران امريكا
تراقب هذه الامور عن كثب علينا ان نفهم
الوضع السياسي في العالم
ولكي نتفادى اي صدام كبير هذا ليس في
مصلحه احد شكرا لك المستشار السابق للرئيس
الامريكي لشؤون الامن القومي ومسؤول شؤون
اليابان في معهد تروم للامن القومي
السابقا ضيفنا من واشنطن وشكرا للسيدس
روكان الباحث في المجلس الروسي لشؤون
الدوليه ضيفنا من موسكو
مزيد من الحديث عن التوتر في المحيط
الهادئ وشرق اسيا والتحالفات المتصاعده
هناك ستكون محور نقاش لنا في فقره في
المتابعه خلال الحصد
[موسيقى]
الان الى المشهد في اوكرانيا حيث تعهد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
بمواصله دعم كييف مهما طال الامر وقال اما
لجنه القوات المسلحه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي ان روسيا استنفذت مخزونها من
العربات المدرعه بشكل لم يكن متخيلا مما
دفعهم لللجوء الى دبابات كبديلا على الارض
تزامنت هذه التصريحات مع وصول دفعات جديده
من الدبابات الغربيه الى كياف فقد قال
وزير الدفاع الامريكي او عفوا الاوكراني
ان بلاده تسلمت دبابات بريطانيه من طراز
تشالنجر اثنين ومدرعات امريكيه بالاضافه
الى مركبات قتاليه الماليه
كل شيء في حينه لم يخبرهم احد متى موعد
الهجوم المضاد الذي تتوعد به قيادتهم صحيح
ان القياده الاوكرانيه شككت اخيرا في
القدره على التنفيذ شرقا او جنوبا في
الوقت الحالي اي ان الدعم الغربي الجديد
الذي حركته احدث استغاثه الرئيس زيلينسكي
ربما عجل به
ها هم الامريكيون يتعهدون بمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا مهما طال الامر قد يكون لي
واشنطن هنا حساباتها الخاصه فوزير الدفاع
تحدث امام لجنه القوات المسلحه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي عن سعي روسيا كما قال
للسيطره على البحر الاسود برمته وحرمان
شركاء واشنطن من الوصول اليه وبشان سير
المعارك يشير استون في تقريره الى ان
الروسس تنفذوا خزينتهم من العربات المدرعه
بشكل لم يكن متخيل مما دفعهم للجوء الى
الدبابات كبديل على الارض
لاعتبارات مشابهه سرع بقيه شركائف وتيره
امدادها بالثقيل والفعال من الاسلحه
تتعزز اذا جبهات القتال بالدبابات
والمدرعات مع استمرار توريد السلاح وذاك
في ظل التقدم الروسي الاخير لاسيما على
الجبهه الشرقيه يؤكد وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
المعدات الجديده ستعزز الوحدات القتاليه
الاوكرانيه وان بلا له ستحرر جميع المدن
الاوكرانيه حسب تعبيره دبابات من البرتغال
ودبابات بريطانيه من طراز تشالنجر 2
ومدرعات امريكيه بالاضافه الى دبابات
ومركبات مشاه قتاليه المانيه من طرازر
كلها بات تحت تصرف القوات الاوكرانيه لا
يروق الامر لموسكو التي التفتت حصرا نحو
برلين اذ اتهمها الكرملين بزياده مستوى
الخراطها في الصراع من خلال المشاركه في
تسليح كييف
لكن هل افلح تدفق السلاح الغربي في قلب
معادله السيطره في الميدان في جبهه الشرق
اللاهبه تواصل قوات فاجنر بحسب مصادر
روسيه شن عملياتها الهجوميه في المناطق
الواقعه شمال وجنوب مدينه
بل وتتقدم اكثر نحو مركز المدينه من
الاتجاهين كما ان قياده المواليه لروسيا
اعلنت سيطره قواتها على المنطقه الصناعيه
يضع كل ذلك مزيدا من الضغط على خطط الرئيس
الاوكراني لاطلاق ما وصف بهجوم الربيع
المضاد
فلا يمكن تنفيذ الهجوم كما قال زيلينسكي
اخيرا بدون دبابات ومدفعيه وراجمات صواريخ
امريكيه لكن حتى مع توالي دفعه الدعم
العسكري يقر مسؤولون غربيون بان التدريب
والتخطيط سيستغرقان بعض الوقت
من بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا يعني هذه ليست المره
الاولى منذ بدايه الحرب التي يتحدث فيها
الطرف الامريكي عن ازمه سلاح لدى روسيا
الان يتحدث لويند اوستن عن ان هناك نقصا
كبيرا في مخزون المدرعات لدى روسيا هل
هناك شواهد على الارض على هذا الكلام
المعلومات هي معلومات ميدانيه هي متابعه
يوميه
نستذكر المرحله الاولى من الحرب كيف
تعثر الجيش الروسي حول كياف وهذه الدبابات
التي دمرت والاهم ال سي هو الهجوم على
خركاف منها السلاح الذي دمر وهي سلاح حديث
من الدبابات ومنها ما هو الذي استولى عليه
الجيش الاوكراني واليوم يستعمله اليوم
عندما يكون الجبهه مفتوحه على 600 كيلو
متر وكلها في مرحله الهجوم والاستنزاف هذا
يؤدي الى استنزاف في العتاد يقال وحسب
المصدر الامريكي ان هناك 800 دبابه من
التي سكس2 والتي تعود الى الستينات قد بدا
اخراجها من المخازن الاستعمالها على كل قد
تستعمل هذه الدبابات فقط كمدفع مركز ثابت
يعني مدفع ثابت بدل عن المدفعيه في القتال
المتقارب في ظل هذا الحديث كيف يفهم
الحديث الروسي عن تقدم نوعي على جبهتي
باخموت
بالطبع يعني اليوم بخمد بعد عشره اشهر
لابد من التقدم بمكان ما ولكن ال سي يجب
ان نرى الصوره الاخرى ما كان الثمن ما هو
الثمن بالبشر وبالحجر وحتى بالعتاد هل وصل
الجيش الاوكراني الجيش الروسي مع فاجنر
الى منطقه الامتداد الاقصى او ما يسمى
بالعلم العسكري يعني بعد هذه الفتره لا
يمكن التقدم لانه تم الاستنزاف اما في
افديفكا فهي قد تشهد مصير مخموض ويقال ان
هناك قوه من فجنر بدات تساعد في عمليه
ولكن اليوم ليس هناك من تحول جذري وخرق في
هذه الجبهات قد تستغرق كما اخذت بخموت في
وقت لاحق طيب الان ايضا يجري الحديث عن
وصول مدرعات ودبابات امريكيه والمانيه
وبريطانيه الى كييف كيف من شان ذلك ان
يؤثر على المعارك ومتى وفي اي جبهات
هناك عده انواع من المدرعات ال سي نتحدث
عن الدبابه او الميل تانك باتل يعني نتحدث
عن
ابرمز لم تاتي بعد هذه دبابه للقتال يجب
ان نتحدث عن حاملات الجند وهي المدرعه مثل
نوع ماردر او سترايكر الامريكيه كلها يجب
ان تقتنم مع بعضها البعض من ضمن مدفعيه من
ضمن دعم جوي دعم صاروخي ودعم مدفعي بكثافه
كي تكتمل الصوره والمنظومه لقتال ما
واليوم هذه الدبابات كلها ثقيله فوق
السبعين او 80 طن وهذا امر لا يناسب اليوم
حاله الارض بسبب ذوبان الثلوج وبدء تشكل
الوحول يعني هذا الامر الصمود في مخموط
والصمودكا هو مرحله لكسب الوقت لتحضير هذه
المرحله لمرحله قد تكون بعد ايار حتى
اشكرك جزيل الشكر العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من
بيروت
اذا تسلمت كييف دفاعات من دبابات او دفعات
من دبابات ومدرعات امريكيه والمانيه
وبريطانيه في هذا العرض نتعرف على انواع
هذه الدبابات وابرز مواصفاتها
تعد دبابات ليبرد اثنان الالمانيه
الموجوده في نحو 20 دوله من افضل
المجنزرات في الغرب فهي من دبابات القتال
الرئيسيه وتبلغ سرعتها القصوى نحو 70 كم
في الساعه تزن الدبابه اكثر من 60 طن وهي
مزوده بمدفع من عيار 120 مليمترا ويمكنها
اصابه الاهداف على مسافه تصل الى خمسه
كيلومترات وتوصف بانها مزيج من الحمايه
والتنقل والقدره على المناوره اما دبابات
تشالنجر اثنان البريطانيه فتزين اكثر من
62 طنا وهي مزوده بمدفع من عيار 120م قادر
على اختراق الدروع وهي دبابه رئيسيه في
الجيش البريطاني تحتوي على درع يؤمن لها
حمايه عاريه وقادر على تحمل الانفجارات
الضخمه مدرعات برادي الامريكيه تزن اكثر
من 27 طنا وهي مزوده بمدفع من عيار خمسه
وعشرين مليمترا وصواريخ خارقه للدروع
تستخدم لنقل الافراد ولها قدره على
الاستطلاع والمناوره والاشتباك وتحتوي على
دروع مضاده للالغام
[موسيقى]
الحرب في اوكرانيا والتوتر في شرق اسيا
كان مدخلا لازمه كبيره فيما يعرف باشباه
الموصلات او الرقائق الالكترونيه التي
يحتاجها العالم في كثير من الصناعات
الاساسيه الولايات المتحده من البلدان
التي تواجه هذا المازق حيث تعتمد بنسبه
كبيره على تايوان لتامين هذه الواردات
واليوم قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
ادارته تعمل على استعاده بلاده الصداره في
هذه الصناعه ان تراجعت عالميا
لكن
الولايات المتحده هي من اخترعت الرقائق
الالكترونيه نحن من اخترعناها بفضل
برنامجنا للفضاء على مدى 30 عاما كانت
امريكا تصنع اربعين في المئه من انتاج
الرقائق العالمي ثم حصل شيء ما واصبح
العمود الفقري الاقتصادنا ايواف وبدل
انتقال المنتجات بدات الشركات والوظائف
تنتقل الى خارج الحدود ونتيجه لذلك نحن
اليوم نصنع حوالي عشره في المئه فقط من
الانتاج العالمي للرقائق الالكترونيه
كبير والاقتصاديين ومدير ابحاث سياسات
التجاره والتصنيع في معهد السياسه
الاقتصاديه في واشنطن
مرحبا بك معنا هل يمتلك الرئيس الامريكي
وهذه الاداره استراتيجيه من اجل تحقيق هذا
الهدف الذي يتحدث عنه اعاده الولايات
المتحده الى صداره الصناعه في اشباه
الموصلات
بكل تاكيد لهذه الاداره
استراتيجيه وهي استراتيجيه مختلفه نحن
نتحدث عن قطاع صناعي مهمه للغايه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهناك دفع
باتجاه التركيز على البحوث والابتكار في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في مجال اشباه
الموصلات الى الصداره او استعاده الصداره
كما يتحدث
كم من الوقت ممكن ان تستغرق
اعتقد ان الامر سوف يتطلب عقدا من الزمن
او اكثر حيث ان الصين وبلدان اخرى في اسيا
امضت عقودا من الزمن تعمل على بناء هذه
القطاعات وبالتالي يتطلب الامر ترتيبا
للارضيه وعملا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهناك قانون في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه خاصه
بالرقائق
وباشباه الموصلات وسوف يؤثر ايجابيا على
موضوع الدفع وتخصيص الاموال خصوصا في مجال
الابتكار والبحوث في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن قيمه
اضافيه وقيمه مضافه مهمه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وتود الولايات المتحده ان تتوس باتجاه
الاسواق الاسيويه كذلك طيب حاليا بروفيسور
روبرت الولايات المتحده تعتمد في هذه
الصناعه على تايوان الى حد بعيد
وكما تعلم يعني منطقه اسيا
تعاني اليوم من توتر كبير
اي توتر وتصاعده كيف يمكن ان ينعكس على
الولايات المتحده في هذا المجال في موضوع
اشباه الموصلات
[موسيقى]
بكل تاكيد ان التوتر يجري ايضا في مناطق
متعدده وفي بلدان متعدده في منطقه اسيا
وهذا موضوع
يجب ان يسلط الضوء عليه ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحاول ان تحافظ على
استقلالها في مجال
الصناعات المختلفه وخصوصا في مجال اشباه
الموصلات
وهذا
تاثر بشكل كبير في التذبذب الذي جرى في
سلاسل الامداد بعد التوترات المختلفه
والنزاعات المختلفه وهذا اثر لربما على
تاجيل الوصول الى هذا الهدف شكرا جزيلا لك
كبير الاقتصاديين ومدير وابحاث سياسات
التجاره والتصنيع في معهد السياسه
الاقتصاديه في واشنطن ضيفنا من العاصمه
الامريكيه
اشباه الموصلات هي تلك الرقائق السوداء
التي تصنع من السيليكون لتتحكم في مرور
التيار الكهربائي ولا يعمل اي جهاز
الكتروني من دونها الرقائق دقيقه الحجم
تدخل في كثير من الصناعات الالكترونيه
كالهواتف الذكيه والحواسيب والسيارات
والطائرات والشبكات المعلوماتيه وصولا
لاجهزه العاب الفيديو ويبلغ حجم سوق
الرقائق العالميه نحو 430 مليار دولار
الصين تستهلك نحو 60% من الانتاج العالمي
لاشباه الموصلات بينما تهيمن تايوان على
نحو 60% من اجمالي التصنيع العالمي لتلك
الرقائق وتعتبر شركه تايوان لتصنيع اشباه
الموصلات الكبرى عالميا بقيمه سوقيه
تتجاوز 600 مليار دولار
الولايه المتحده تستورد من تايوان 90% من
استهلاكها من تلك الرقائق ما يعد وفق
وزيره التجاره الامريكيه ثغره امنيه تلك
المخاوف الامريكيه دفعت واشنطن لتخصيص 52
مليار دولار لدعم قطاع الرقائق
الالكترونيه على اراضيها كما انها اوقفت
تصدير الرقائق واشباه الموصلات الى الصين
كجزء من حرب تكنولوجيه تشنها على
[موسيقى]
اعلنت احزاب المعارضه الاسرائيليه انتهاء
الاجتماع الاول الذي انعقد في منزل الرئيس
اسحاق هرتوك واكدت انها ستبذل قصار جهدها
لانجاح ما سمتها المهمه الوطنيه المتمثله
في الحفاظ على ديمقراطيه ووحده الشعب
اضافت انها ستعزز في الايام المقبله سير
العمل داعيه الائتلاف الحكومي الى التصرف
بمسؤوليه خلال الاجتماعات وفي الميادين
العامه ايضا
وفي سياق تعليقه على اعلان وزير الامن
القومي اتمار بن جير اتفاقه مع نتنياهو
على التصديق على انشاء الحرس الوطني قال
زعيم المعارضه انه من الافضل ان لا يؤسس
حرس وطني تحت عمره بن جزير ووصفه بمهرج
التيك توك الخطير الذي لم يخدم في الجيش
لدقيقه واحده واتهم لبيد في حديث مع موقع
يدعوت احرونوتانياهو بتقديم وعود يدرك انه
لن ينفذها ووصف الخطوه بالجنونيه
عكست الازمه القائمه في اسرائيل اثارها
على وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وبينما
تباينت اراء المحللين والسياسيين بشان
الازمه ومالاتها اتفقت وسائل الاعلام على
ان الشرخ الداخلي وصل الى مستوى غير مسبوق
تلقي الازمه الداخليه المستمره في اسرائيل
بظلالها على الصحافه الاسرائيليه
الخضوع الجزئي الذي اعلنه نتنياهو لمطالب
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه لم يغير الاوضاع بل
زاد الشكوك والريبه
الذي قال فيه نتنياهو لمقر بيه انه لا
ينوي التوقف بل تهدئه الاجواء ان حاول ذلك
سيجد في مواجهته مئات الالاف من الوطنيين
الاسرائيليين الذين يصممون على ان يكونوا
الدرع الواقيه للدوله اليهوديه
الديمقراطيه
وعلى وقع الاحتجاجات وتراجع شعبيه الحكومه
استطاع وزير الامن القومي المتطرف اطمار
بنكفير انتزاع موافقه نتنياهو على تشكيل
ما سمي بالحرس الوطني تحت امرته الاتفاق
الذي رافق الاعلان عن تجميد الاصلاحات
القضائيه كان كسك بالزيت على النار في نظر
بعض المحللين الاس
في اللحظه التي يعطي فيها نتنياهو الحرس
الوطني ويضعه تحت امره وزارته فاننا سنصبح
على عتبه اللا ديمقراطيه ويمكن وصف ذلك
بانه اقامه حرس للثوره
سياسيون ومحللون ابدو مخاوفهم من ان رئاسه
الوطني قد تسفر عن ظهور ميليشيات خاصه
داخل الدوله وتمنح المتهربين من الخدمه
العسكريه غطاء قانونيه
[موسيقى]
عن رفض الخدمه العسكريه وانتم ترددون خلفه
فيجب ان يعلم انه يعتمد في حكومته على
المتهربين من الخدمه العسكريه نتنياهو هو
الذي ادخل لاول مره الى المبادئ الاساسيه
لحكومه اسرائيل بندا لحمايه المتهربين من
الخدمه العسكريه
في الجانب الاخر لا يبدو ان كل تلك
الاصوات المرتفعه بالانتقاد قد غيرت فعليا
رؤيه المتطرفين من اعضاء الحكومه اليمينيه
في المضي قدما لاجراء ما سمي بالاصلاحات
القضائيه
يجب الاشاره الى ما خسرته دوله اسرائيل
لان اجراء الاصلاحات القضائيه كان لصالح
كل مواطني اسرائيل اعتقد اننا في وضع
تحسين المواقع
ومع استمرار المظاهرات والاحتجاجات واثرها
على المزاج الشعبي وما ينتج عنه من صيغ
سياسيه جديده في اسرائيل تتفق وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه على ان الشرخ
الداخليه وصل الى مستويات غير مسبوخه
[موسيقى]
الهادئ هذه المره الرسائل كانت اكثر قربا
الى اذن اليابان بعد زياره رئيس وزرائها
لاوكرانيا هكذا تبدو اطلاله روسيا على هذا
المحيط وهكذا يبدو جوارها مع اليابان جوار
قريب جدا ومحتدم ولطالما شهد العديد من
السجلات والنزاعات فمثلا نرى هنا اقليم
بريموري المطور الروسي المطل على اليابان
وفيه نقطه اشتباك محتمله ليس مع اليابان
فقط بل مع الولايات المتحده ايضا حيث تجري
هناك مناورات مشتركه وتنفذ طلعات جويه
امريكيه تقابلها اخرى روسيه اما هنا فنرى
جزر كيوريل كما تسميها روسيا او الجزر
الشماليه بالمسمى الياباني ويدعي كلا
البلدين امتداد حدوده الى اربع جزر في
اقصى جنوب الارخبيل ولا تكمن الاهميه في
المساحه من حيث المبدا
الموقع الجيو استراتيجي لها فضلا عن غناها
بكثير من الثروات كالنفط والغاز ومعادن
مهمه بالاضافه الى الثروات البحريه
الكبيره لا يمكن عزل ما يجري بين اليابان
وروسيا عن مجريات سجال عالميا وفي تلك
المنطقه تزداد سياسه التحالفات يوما بعد
اخر
اليابان جزء من تحالف معلن تقوده الولايات
المتحده ويضم الهند واستراليا ويسمى
بتحالف كواد كما انشئ تحالف اخر هناك يضم
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا وهو
تحالف اوكس في المقابل تواصل روسيا والصين
تحركات مشتركه تتمثل في تقارب متزايد
ومناورات مشتركه تزداد وتيرتها في منطقه
المحيط الهادئ المزيد حول هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من الدكتور ادوارد حول الاستاذ
العلاقات الدوليه المختص بشؤون شرق اسيا
بجامعه اوكسفورد دكتور حاول مرحبا بك
نقترب معك اكثر من خارطه التحالفات الاخذه
في التشكل في المنطقه
والتحولات التي تجري هناك
اعتقد انه هو في البدايه يجب ان لا نفرط
في تقدير
التحالفات بين روسيا والصين بلدان الاخرى
في المنطقه في حقيقه الامر نحن نرى ان
روسيا تقوم بمناورات عسكريه
في هذه المنطقه ولقد راينا اطلاق الصاروخ
الفرط الصوتي في بحر اليابان هذا يسلط
الضوء على التغيرات التي يشهدها العالم
وهذا الرد من قبل الروس حول ما يحصل في
العالم
ولكن برايي يجب ان لا نفرط في تسليط الضوء
على هذا الموضوع حيث ان هذا يندرج في سياق
ما يحدث في العالم
لماذا باعتقادك لا يجب ان نفرض في تسليط
الضوء لا سيما ان هناك توترا متصاعدا تشهد
المنطقه مناورات مكثفه من
التحالفات الاخذه في من كلا التحالفات
الاخيره في التشكل
باعتقادك يعني ما مالات الامور هناك ما
الذي يمكن ان يحصل
اعتقد انه يجب
ان لا نصلي الضوء على هذا الموضوع
بالتحديد من ضمن استراتيجيه جديده وتحالف
جديد بين الصين وروسيا نحن نعرف ان هذا
تحالف قائم اصلا وتشيجن تحدث مع بوتين
بخصوص هذا الموضوع نحن نعرف ان اليابان
لديه تحالفات واضحه ورئيس مجلس الوزراء
الياباني اوضح بشكل لا لبس فيه ان البلد
يتابع المناورات العسكريه الروسيه على وجه
الخصوص برايي ان ما يحصل في المنطقه في
اليابان ولكن في المنطقه بيروماتها هذا
يندرج في سياق الرد الروسي وذلك في سياق
دولي الح رب في اوكرانيا
والرد على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
خصوصا في تحالفاتها مع كوريا الجنوبيه ومع
اليابان هناك
تقاربا استراتيجيا روسيا صينيا يحاول كل
من البلدين التاكيد على
قوته متانته وفعاليته في العالم هذا
الموضوع كيف من شانه ان يتبلور في المنطقه
هناك
عبرت عن موقف متوقع والصين وروسيا لديهما
تقارب يحاول البلدان ان يشكل
شراكه استراتيجيه جديده كما عبر عنها
في حقيقه الامر يجب ان نتنبه الى حقيقه ان
التحالفات الغربيه وركنها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذه التحالفات مع كوريا
الجنوبيه ومع اليابان ومع البلدان الاخرى
هذه تحالفات على مستوى واسع النطاق ولا
يمكن ان تقارن بالتحالف او بهذا بهذه
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الجديده بين روسيا
والصين يجب ان نتابع ما يحصل بين البلدين
وايضا يجب ان نتنبه الى الجهات الفاعله
الاخرى المنطقه بما في ذلك كوريا الشماليه
نعرف التفاعل بين كوريا الشماليه وروسيا
والتبادلات على مستوى العسكري بين هذين
البلدين وعلى ذكر كوريا الشماليه وفي ظل
التهديدات الكوريه الشماليه المتصاعده
كذلك
واطلاق الصواريخ
المكثف كيف من شان ذلك ان ينعكس على
التحالفات في المنطقه ولا سيما على حلفاء
الولايات المتحده
نعم في حقيقه الامر نحن نعرف ان كوريا
الشماليه تحاول ان تقوم باستعراض للعضلات
وهذا تكتيك معتمد من قبل القياده في كوريا
الشماليه
وتقوم
بهذه المناورات
وتستفيد كوريا الشماليه من الوضع المتوتر
في المنطقه وفي العالم
وروسيا والصين تتقاربان من بعضهما البعض
هذا هو الوضع من جهه ومن جهه اخرى لدينا
التحالف الغربي وهذا ما ظهر على مستوى
مجلس الامن التابعه للامم المتحده
وبالتالي يتعين علينا ان
نتذكر ان الصين تحاول ان تستفيد هي كذلك
من الوضع في المنطقه من الدكتور ادوارد
هول الاستاذ والعلاقات الدوليه المختص
بشؤون شرق اسيا بجامعه اوكسفورد شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله نتوقف عند
مشهد سياسيا لافت في اسكتلندا حمزه يوسف
مسلم من اصل باكستاني يبلغ من العمر 37
عاما يتسلم رئاسه الحكومه وزعامه الحزب
الحاكم ويخوض مع حزبه كما يقول سعيا جديدا
نحو الاستقلال عن المملكه المتحده التي
يقابله فيها
ريشيسونيك رئيس الوزراء ذو الاصول الهنديه
الذي يسعى جاهدا لتجاوز ازمات الاقتصاد
مفارقه حملت شابين تحت عنوان الكفاءه
والقدره والمواطنه لا اللون ولا دين ولا
الاصل لمواجهه قضايا مصيريه في حياه
الشعوب نهايه الحصاد شكرا لمتابعتكم
نترككم الان مع ليلى وعثمان ومنتصف الليل